les anglais c'est bien connu adore les
animaux est un chercheur s'est passionné
pour les relations entre les chiens et
leurs maîtres au point de braquer sa
caméra sur un couple maître chien
pendant 400 heures il s'est aperçu qu
entre les deux s'exerçait une sorte de
télépathie à grande distance
étienne nena notre correspondant à
londres voici dit
devenue célèbre depuis qu'il a accepté
d'être le cobaye d'une expérience in its
pendant plusieurs centaines d'heures de
jti et sa maîtresse ont été filmés
qu'ils soient ensemble ou à des
kilomètres l'un de l'autre
regardez en bas de l'image l'heure
tourne et lorsque pam smart décide de
rentrer chez elle son chien jti à
plusieurs kilomètres de là est quasiment
à la seconde près réagi se lève et
s'approche de la porte d'entrée
expérience renouvelée des dizaines de
fois et à des heures différentes
rencontres que nous avons eues ex 44
expérience comme celle-ci et sur l'e40
cadre il a réagi 38 fois au moment
précis où je décidé de rentrer chez moi
quelle que soit l'heure et l'endroit où
je me trouvais on joue à l'expérience à
ce biologiste dont les travaux tendent à
prouver qu'il existe autre chose qu'une
simple explication scientifique au
comportement des chiens ce qu'il reste
cette expérience est une relation
invisible que la science n'a pas encore
expliqué appelez ça comme vous voulez et
télépathie liam si chic sixième sens
moi je l'appelle un champ mort fiq passé
ce chien pour les 7 millions de
britanniques qui promènent leur chien le
champ mort fille qui est une aubaine
leur affection débordante se doublerait
donc d'une communion des esprits
du coup les témoignages abondent et
anonymes jusque dans les plus hautes
sphères de la monarchie une fois je suis
parti en vacances sans lui pendant trois
semaines le jour même il a disparu ou
les revenus le jour de mon retour
dix minutes avant je rentre le soir il
sort de son panier fâché sur les marchés
le matin reine elizabeth est persuadé
que ces chiens ont des capacités
mentales remarquable et elle les
considère comme ses enfants elle leur
porte beaucoup d'amour et d'affection
que la reine prête autant d'attention à
ces chiens qu'aux membres de sa famille
en laissera certains rêveurs
le biologiste lui va braquer maintenant
ses caméras sur les oiseaux et les
serpents mais pas sur les chats dans
l'indépendance légendaire dit il n'est
pas compatible avec la télépathie